unlike in live-action cinematography
lighting in animation is something
that's built totally from scratch in
other words while in live-action light
is controlled sometimes too brilliant
effect in animation light is created of
course these days a lot of animated
light is computer-generated meaning that
virtual lights can be placed in 3d
environments and actually play off solid
surfaces like they would in real life
like the control of actual lights this
too can be used to beautiful effect but
today I want to talk about lighting as
it was done in traditional hand-drawn
cel animation particularly in the
groundbreaking anime film by Katsuhiro
Otomo Akira
now Kira is well known for its
painstaking animation every frame of the
film was composed with the closest
attention to detail and color and that
gives it an unmatched richness and soul
for this reason Akira is also a film
that's been painstakingly picked over
and analyzed by others but one thing I
haven't heard much about is the way that
lighting is used by the filmmakers
because I see the film's many lights
they're different qualities and textures
as a powerful motif and symbol and a
vital element of its genius
the sender Lloyd's and backgrounds must
still be photographed by the master
camera in Technicolor here the operator
puts a Donald Duck celluloid on top of a
background as the overhead camera
exposes one frame of film
like I said Akira was a film made in the
cell animation style developed in the
first half of the 20th century which
involves drawing and painting on two
transparent slides and layering them
over a background frames composed like
this were photographed and strung
together to create the animation this 2d
traditional style coupled with the
tropes of anime means that the light in
Akira is quite specific and pronounced
the lines between shadow and light are
distinct and evocative in the same way
that film noir lighting is and like in
film noir light in Akira is intimately
connected to the city at night this for
example is the very first shot after the
opening credits of flickering neon sign
for the neighborhood bar where cañedo is
waiting for his friends nothing could
more concisely communicate the rundown
to Staubach feeling of the future tokyo
Otomo is going to present us with in the
very next shot and throughout the film
indeed this is a city as sordid romantic
and multifarious as the lights that
slash across its million surfaces to
make a delicate hole the city where the
disenfranchised young marked their
presence and their personalities with
the streaks of light that their
motorcycles leave behind a city where
authority is as much a blinding
spotlight as it is a gun or badge
Oh Toma has said that he wanted Tokyo
itself to be a major character in Akira
and one of the ways he flushes this out
is with light particularly neon neon has
a special significance for both Tokyo
and the cyberpunk genre it is the bitter
but beautiful light that signifies both
the colorful radiance and the gaudy
consumerism of modernity the dark
dystopic side of which remains
cyberpunks basic focus tokyo for its
part has been a cultural hub for neon
signage ever since 1957 when the Totsuka
company unveiled its giant 30-foot neon
billboard in the Ginza district
revealing its new name Sony since then
the signs have proliferated becoming a
signature even a
attraction of Tokyo's night scape and
novels like William Gibson's Neuromancer
films like Blade Runner took the vivid
and suggestive qualities of Tokyo's neon
for a tech saturated future akira
continues this tradition but here the
neon quality infuses all the light
sources of the film both inside and out
there's the neon on the buildings but
there's also the neon bright screens
that shine in the characters faces and
the neon control panels of bright
primary colors the spotlights that Rove
in the sky are like giant neon tubes
being waved back and forth machine-gun
fire is a barrage of neon streaks even
the sunlight shining in through the
windows has a bluish neon quality to it
in neon neon ochio and its inhabitants
aren't so much lit as caught caught in
this huge incandescent web that serves
only the mandates of money capital in
that web government is as impotent as a
biker gang made up of disaffected
children it's funny that industry
business is notably absent from the
film's plot because its DNA seems to be
in the corners of everything I mean
blinking you might miss a news reader at
the beginning of the movie shining from
another flickering light source
reporting riots of unemployed workers
after tax reforms maybe this is why
Tetsuo and once the protagonist and the
antagonist of the film a boy who gains
extraordinary psychic power so often
produces a disruption in the light
around him whether it's in his own mind
or in the form of explosion or in the
aura around him even in the vibrant
dancing wavelength that his brain
patterns create indeed psychic power
most fully realize in Tetsuo and his
counterpoint Akira represent the only
kind of power that can have an effect on
the state of things in the Oh Tokyo this
is perhaps the reason that the
protesters turned to Akira for their
salvation because even when the
authorities turned their biggest
spotlight on him a mega satellite laser
that takes the name of our son
he comes out the victor in the end the
salvation represented in Tetsuo comes at
the cost of ruin a catastrophe which
consumes Neo Tokyo in the form of a
giant ball of light one single uniform
white light that erases the countless
artificial lights of the city Otomo
seems to suggest that there's some
freedom in this some rebirth as true
sunlight wipes across the city in
patches when you have to draw light 24
times in every second of a two-hour
movie
it must be the case that you gain a new
appreciation for how it can tell a story
of its own and that's what a Tomo and
his crew have done in akhirah light is
layered into the story like it's layered
into the animation cells pointing toward
meaning behind the film at the corners
of it and illuminating from different
angles the characters and their place in
this neon world in other words akira is
a great example of how you animate light
hey everybody it is great to be back
home back to work and back on schedule
finally if you want to subscribe to this
channel by the way you can click right
there that box over there I have to
thank Frenchy role for sponsoring this
video if you don't know what my role is
it's like a great service where you can
access tons of different anime shows and
movies obviously I love anime I love
Akira but you can get stuff like an hour
after it airs on TV in Japan on
crunchyroll I want to recommend one its
Cowboy Bebop you haven't seen it it is
an amazing and amazing show might
actually analyze it sometime in the
future but um anyway they're a great
service they do really HD episodes you
can get it on Apple TV or Roku or
whatever you have and if you sign up at
crunchyroll.com slash nerdwriter you can
get a free 30-day trial which is awesome
and they're awesome for sponsoring the
show without interfering in the content
in any way or asking - thank you guys
for that and I'll see everybody else
next Wednesday